bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre 12
13 ans en basse normandie en direct ce
vendredi à nouveau du village des jeux
équestres mondiaux des jeux qui se
poursuivent jusqu'à dimanche soir la
compétition tire à sa fin avec en ce
moment même les finales de la voltige et
la suite du dressage en attelage nous en
parlerons dans un instant mais avant
cela florent turpin bonjour vous
l'attendiez avec impatience deuxième
médaille française d'hier soir avec
l'équipe de france de saut d'obstacles
et c'est à trois cavaliers calvadosien
oui deuxième médaille française deuxième
médaille d'argent on va l'avoir c'était
après midi au stade de michel d'ornano
devant 20000 spectateurs est dans une
super ambiance une ambiance de stade de
foot les français sur la deuxième marche
du podium donc grâce notamment aux
performances des trois cavaliers
bas-normands on va les voir
pénélope leprévost kevin staut et
patrice delaveau patrice delaveau qui
aurait même pu offrir la médaille d'or à
l'équipe de france il n'avait pas commis
cette petite erreur sur son dernier
passage dommage pour les français qui
peuvent bien sûr se réjouir de cette
deuxième place juste derrière l'équipe
des pays bas ici à l'image des
hollandais qui décroche donc la médaille
d'or
et vous allez voir ça vaut bien une
petite cabriole pour fêter sa médaille
effectivement ont bien fêté hier soir
pour toutes les équipes ouais les
cavaliers hollandais qui ont rejoint un
supporters quelques minutes après cette
cérémonie de remise des médailles
c'était un bar situé juste en face du
stade michel d'ornano champagne et
chaude ambiance les supporters
hollandais qui sont aux nombreux en
normandie depuis le début de ces jeux
équestres mondiaux
mais regardez un peu plus tard les
cavaliers de l'équipe de france ont
également été chaleureusement accueillis
par leurs supporters au village des jeux
avant de faire la tournée des plateaux
de télévision vous les voyez
ici ou aller voir chez nos confrères
d'equidia sous les applaudissements du
public
philippe gardaz bonjour vous êtes
sélectionneur français de cette équipe
de ce fait d'être avec nous dans ce
12-13 belle victoire française comment
est ce que vous avez vécu cette cette
journée d'hier
c'est toujours un petit peu le même
format pour moi c'est quelque chose à
quoi je m'étais de long c'est déjà une
victoire j'ai parlé de victoire mais
mais ça n'est pas si j'allais vous
reprendre aussi basses pour moi ce n'est
pas une victoire
c'est une super performance mais c'est
sûr que nous ne sommes pas champions du
monde aujourd'hui alors que nous on
était tous très de l'être
le sport est devenu tellement compliqué
à haut niveau que si on regarde les
résultats on aurait très bien pu
terminer 6e dont il vraiment déjà eu une
grande performance de mes calculs au gré
malgré tout si vous vous entends bien
oui parce que aimé offrir un titre à la
france et surtout que j'avais des
équipes de cavaliers pour le faire
j'ai peut-être même fait l'erreur
tactique moi même parce que on avait des
ordres un petit peu avec patrice et
peut-être si j'avais orienter
différemment peut-être il n'aurait pas
fait la faute chu 3 mais on sait jamais
refaire l'histoire à 13,0 sur le podium
il avait un sourire crispé on y touche
une petite barre qui ne permet pas
d'avoir la médaille d'or et ce qu'il
était il y avait un peu de frustration
un peu de déception non match et qu'il
aurait bien aimé offrir le titre pas
seulement ses camarades mais vraiment à
ce public était extraordinaire hier il
faut pas oublier que c'est lui qui nous
a attiré une épine du pied et que tout
le monde va participer vraiment à ceux à
ce succès j'attends en plus parler les
trois détroit normand il ya aussi un
quatrième avec eux même si les prix
seront honnêtement oui mais je pense que
et qu'on avait un réserviste au site
était fantastique et formidable
j'attends moi j'oublie personnes dans
mes réflexions est vraiment à cela la
récompense pour toute une équipe et pour
deux années de travail
cette deuxième place l'équipe est
qualifiée pour les jeux olympiques c'est
quelque chose de qui fait qu'il fallait
c'est une satisfaction pour vous alors
c'est pour moi au départ que c'était ça
parce que j'étais engagé à deux ans
maintenant c'était vraiment essayé de
préparer quelque chose pour rio après le
problème qu'avait connu l'équipe de
france à londres
c'est un passage obligé bien sûr parce
que les jeux mondiaux chez nous c'est
quelque chose de très important mais je
vais répéter dix fois cent fois il
fallait d'abord se qualifier pour les
jeux etc
samedi et dimanche il y aura la finale
en individuel on peut espérer encore une
médaille
on peut espérer une médaille il faut
d'abord qu'on se qualifier à on a une
petite chance de se qualifier dans le
les quatre derniers mais il ya deux gros
parcours devant nous et ira jouer à très
peu de choses encore une fois peut-être
que la faute de hyères m'a coûté
beaucoup à patrice on sait pas on fera
les comptes samedi soir mais tout le
monde est préparé à donner le meilleur
de lui-même demain on tu vois ça merci à
vous fait des guerres d'être venu et
nous nous vous que cette belle médaille
française sur ce plateau du 12/13
florent de la voltige est également
conduit à l'heure des finales
oui regardez ça se passe en ce moment
même et en direct au zénith de caen
dernière journée pour ces compétitions
de voltige c'est l'heure des premiers
podiums
une journée est décisive puisque toutes
les finales se déroulent depuis 10h ce
matin des finales en pâte de 1 c
notamment ses podiums c'est très
spectaculaire depuis ce matin que
regarder côté français on va le voir on
rêve aujourd'hui de décrocher deux
médailles en individuel chez les garçons
puisque nicolas andréani et jacques
ferrari sont bien partis pour monter sur
le podium avant leur dernier passage cet
après-midi ce sera après 16 heures on
croise les doigts pour eux oui et par
équipes l'équipe de france est
actuellement quatrième au classement
l'équipe jouera disputera sa finale cet
après midi une équipe de france qu'on
rencontre est clair wauquiez figo et
frédéric bazille
de la cigogne a migré en normandie avec
l'intention de se poser sur le podium
anthony totaux rémy duda lac léman fifou
nathalie inat cristal crise robin thicke
où ils sont attachés de clientèle à
chandon entretient ou collégiens cinq
fois champion de france médaillée de
bronze aux derniers championnats
d'europe et du monde
tous ont beaucoup travaillé pour être à
la hauteur de l'événement c'est vrai
qu'ils ont organisé leur vie vraiment
autour de autour de cette équipe autour
de cet événement donc on a des gens qui
ont beaucoup l'envi quoi on certain
grain de folie mais je pense que c'est
aussi leur marque de fabrique et
mais surtout très travailleur pas très
beau score une ampleur se faire
robin 13 ans est le petit frère de la
bande dans les autres pays on trouve
souvent une fille dans le rôle du poids
plume
mais cette équipe est à l'image de
l'exception française en voltige une
prédominance masculine
il ya beaucoup plus de filles d'une
manière générale que de garçons la
discipline non moins sept personnes sont
plus forte et beaucoup plus fort que
lippi plus fort le dernier atout de
cette équipe c'est un cheval
exceptionnel parmi
meilleurs du circuit
et cette équipe de france de voltige
entrera en piste précisément ce soir
pour la finale florent ensuite également
des épreuves d'attelage mais l'attelage
qui se poursuit en ce moment même à
l'hippodrome de caen comme hier place à
l'épreuve de dressage costume chapeau
c'est vrai c'est pas hyper spectaculaire
mais c'est très technique
vous voyez à l'image le français fabrice
martin a les français qui sont pour
l'instant au milieu de classement en
attendant le marathon demain et la
maniabilité dimanche deux des temps
forts de ces jeux équestres mondiaux
effectivement vous l'avez dit florent
épreuves du marathon demain le long des
rives de l'orne pour la classe paul
vincent marchand bonjour vous êtes
directeur logistique de ces jeux
équestres mondiaux ce marathon c'est
toute une organisation à mettre en place
ah oui c'est comme pour tous les sites
une grosse organisation à mettre en
place un ca présente évidemment des
contraintes des tankers de ville mais en
même temps c'est magnifique de pouvoir
accueillir seize mille spectateurs
demain sur sur ce site de l'hippodrome
qui tient à coeur les caennais en
particulier très concrètement justement
pour ses cannes et il y aura des voies
fermées en raison de ce marathon alors
les seules voies fermées selon ce qu'on
appelle les voies vertes au niveau de la
vallée de l'orne donc une coupure pour
pour le passage pour le passage des
vélos et des piétons pour des raisons de
sécurité un principalement et éviter des
croisements avec avec avec des attelages
sinon l'ensemble des voies de
circulation sont ouvertes pour justement
fluidifier au maximum avec les
conseillers alors bien sûr on
déconseille
aux habitants de caen qui ne viennent
pas sur les jeux de d'éviter le secteur
de l'hippodrome de la prairie
demain le secteur sera surchargé même si
on a on a un dispositif de circulation à
guichet fermé les seize mille places ont
trouvé preneurs mais ça c'est 1000
places ont trouvé preneur très
rapidement donc oui c'est à guichet
fermé alors encore des possibilités pour
voir les preuves la ville de caen mais
retransmet le marathon d'attelages sur
écran géant au niveau des rives de
l'orne est ici au village en invite les
spectateurs qui n'auraient pas de place
à venir aussi regarder sur écrans géants
cette épreuve et et profiter du village
pour l'endurance a certes il avait été
possible de voir gratuitement la course
en se plaçant à des endroits bien bien
conseillé cette fois ça ne sera pas
possible
non non c'est pas possible pour des
raisons que d'évoquer les raisons
principalement de sécurité au niveau au
niveau de la vallée de l'orne merci à
vous paul vincent marchand d'être venu
parler de ce marathon de l'attelage qui
aura lieu demain dans donc à caen dans
ces jeux équestres mondiaux merci à vous
on va passer à présent au reste de
l'actualité on viendra un peu plus tard
sur ces jeux équestres mondiaux avec
d'abord après 48 heures de perturbations
la distribution du courrier qui va
progressivement rentrer dans l'ordre
dans
18 communes de l'agglomération caennaise
les facteurs de la forme de distribution
du courrier de colombelles ont voté ce
matin la reprise du travail ils ont
obtenu des garanties sur l'emploi
une rentrée scolaire agitée à l'école
albert-camus de condé sur noireau les
parents d'élèves ont décidé ce matin de
bloquer l'école on en parlera dans un
instant pour l'or revenant sur les
déserts médicaux dans le rhône c'est le
nombre de médecins s'est stabilisé ces
des nazes ces dernières années la
crainte d'une pénurie de généralistes
est toujours vive pour preuve ce chiffre
57 ans et l'âge moyen des médecins dans
le département dans un camp qui viennent
le désert médical pourrait revenir au
grand galop reportage dames et mignot et
patrick mertz le 1er janvier 2016
le docteur de gaulle décrochera sa
plaque de médecins une décision mûrement
réfléchie après 35 ans d'activité et une
moyenne de 60 heures semaine seule ombre
au tableau l'absence de remplaçant et le
sentiment d'abandonner sa clientèle
cerrone fatigue
c'est vrai qu'il serait intéressant de
passer la main et c'est surtout
intéressant de trouver un confrère qui
on puisse faire partager je dirais notre
expérience second inconnu seconde a fait
parce que je reste persuadé que le trail
de messagerie cinq ans par n est quand
même de chose de fantastique et de mer
dans l'orne près d'un médecin sur deux a
plus de 60 ans une situation critique
qui pourrait devenir catastrophique dans
les cinq ans depuis 2008 une cellule
travaille activement sur ce dossier elle
a permis notamment l'installation de
quelques médecins étrangers
mais aujourd'hui la piste privilégiée et
l'accueil des jeunes étudiants a dit
qu'on accueille à peu près dans l'orne
150 étudiants parents qui permet leur
permettre de découvrir l'homme mais
aussi qu qui va permettre aussi à
certains d'entre eux de rester dans le
département il y en a déjà certains qui
règne puisque contrairement aux années
précédentes on vouloir venir des
étudiants berd'huis et un médecin qui
s'installe et des arrivées qui ne
permettent pas pour l'instant de
compenser les départs
mais le dr galles paris sur ces
nouvelles structures
les pôles de santé pas rentrer y aura de
secrétariat
bush d espace pluridisciplinaire qui
permettrait aux médecins d'éviter
l'isolément et de mu l'a ménagé leur vie
professionnelle
deux étudiants sur trois sont des femmes
avec des aménagements d'horaires
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour les
femmes de s'intégrer aussi dans ces
pôles de santé avec des horaires
aménagés l'année prochaine quarante six
professionnels investiront ce bâtiment
en attendant des structures satellites
risque de disparaître
le confrère du docteur de gaulle a lui
aussi décidé de raccrocher de peur entre
eux d'être submergé par la clientèle
côté éducation une rentrée 2014 sous le
signe de la réforme des quatre jours et
demi pour tous une révolution qu'il en
est pas une pour 20 % des communes qui
avaient accepté d'instaurer la réforme
dès l'an dernier ainsi à valognes dans
la manche où après un an
d'expérimentation le système est
désormais rôdé reportage à stéphanie
potet sylvain rouil 15h45
mais oui mais oui l'école est finie et
pendant trois quarts d'heure quatre fois
par semaine par groupe de maximum 14
élève ses enfants peuvent découvrir
musique yoga langue des signes bridge et
la liste proposée est longue
à chaque vacances le calendrier
d'activités s'enrichit de nouvelles
disciplines
pour les enfants c'est l'occasion de se
découvrir autrement les autres
cinquante ans ils sont en travail de
groupe comme boys de sporting en équipe
donc faut bien savoir en et kim à
valognes
la municipalité applique la réforme à la
lettre ici pas de cumul sur une
demi-journée des temps aménagé mais bien
un allègement quotidien de la journée
d'école des activités proposées dans les
établissements pour éviter la fatigue en
transport des élèves augmentation de la
masse salariale formation du personnel
encadrant mise aux normes
2 pourquoi adapter la municipalité a
investi gros pour ses 470 élèves et à la
fin de l'année à venir c'est sans l'aide
de l'état 100 euros par l avais parents
que la municipalité devra continuer
l'application de la réforme
c'est un paradoxe que de nous demander
toujours plus toujours plus d'activités
pour nous les collectivités locales et
dans le même temps de nous demander
également d'alléger les charges et la
masse salariale d'après des enseignants
les enfants seraient moins fatigués et
l'autre effet c'est que de nombreux
enfants se sont inscrits dans des clubs
pour approfondir les activités
découvertes et puis je voulais voter il
ya quelques instants une rentrée
scolaire agité cette fois l'école
albert-camus de condé sur noireau les
parents d'élèves ont décidé de bloquer
l'école ce matin ils ont appris cette
semaine la fermeture d'une classe sur
place rémi mauger et guillaume quick à
condé tout ferme
c'est ce qu'il se disait ce matin devant
leur école peau de chagrin
et pourtant c'est rentré ne s'annonçait
pas si mal et puis boum
mercredi enfin maintenir en récupérant
les enfants à 11h30
on était homo mis au courant donc une
classe fermée alors que le mardi il en
était la directrice a fait l'appel et
le problème ne s'était pas posée en fait
faute d'élèves la direction académique
supprime une classe ici à camus au
profit de la varende une autre école de
condé le maire aussi a été mis devant le
fait accompli
la décision est tombée mardi soir et moi
d'une certaine façon on me demande tu te
coupe le bras droit au bras gauche
ces délégations de parents a été reçue à
la mairie en début de matinée
elle en est revenue avec un message à
partager il faut se dire que l'année
prochaine sur faire encore des élèves ce
sera encore une place de perdue et qu'au
bout du compte on ferme à une place donc
il vaut mieux faire une fusion correct
est dans les clous
plutôt que de perdre des classes petit à
petit est fermé alors je sais que c'est
durant je sais que c'est pas facile à
entendre pour vous on sait aussi que
c'est en fait c'est le souhait de
l'inspection en faisant ça on on essaie
aussi d'une certaine façon donc la
contrepartie ce steak au moins pour
cette année scolaire là il nous
maintiennent le poste à kaboul
c'est du donnant donnant on sauve les
meubles cette année et on ferme l'an
prochain le chantier d'à côté n'est pas
pour la future école aller plus loin
c'est l'âme du quartier c'est l'âme d'un
autre coin et on nous supprime encore
une chose c'est notre école honeywell a
fermé le ps est là va ouvrir aalborg
beau ouvrir une nouvelle usine toute
neuve avec des gros investissements
voilà on est en mutation ça c'est clair
on est en mutation sait tout faire mâcon
des dix aussi les maires en colère ce
que tempère monsieur le maire qui est il
faut le dire en campagne électorale
et puis côté culture clap de début ce
soir pour le festival du cinéma
américain de deauville pour son 40e
anniversaire le rendez vous accueillera
à nouveau du beau monde mick jagger
brosnan costa brava ou encore abel
ferrara l'occasion ce midi de jeter un
coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur du
festival franck binet revient sur la
toute première édition
mais été 1975 il ya foule sur les
planches à deauville en l'espace d'un
siècle ce petit village du bord de mer
est devenue une station balnéaire chic
et connu du monde entier mais deauville
en veut plus michel d'ornano son père
lui offre un événement nous sommes le 3
septembre 34 je déclare ouvert ce
premier festival de deauville du cinéma
américain anne d'ornano son épouse et
rayonnante est dira plus tard
hollywood se trouvait un verger rarement
dit
c'est le début de la télé en couleurs
les acteurs du premier film
nashville de robert altman arrivée en
carrosse les figures du cinéma français
ont fait des placements mais deux villes
ne veut pas ressembler à cannes c'est un
festival américain certes mais sans âme
et sans compétition j'ai horreur des
décorations mais les comités de quel
qu'il soit et c'est si j'ai accepté de
se figurer si vous voulez nantes dans ce
comité de parrainage c'est parce que le
cinéma américain est vraiment ce qui
nous a poussé beaucoup d'entre nous à
devenir metteur en scène ccc finaux
merveilleux que nous voyons quand on
avait des culottes courtes
et à l'époque on ne se doutait pas
encore qu'en l'espace de quarante ans
deauville verrait passer toutes les
stars du cinéma américain toujours en
direct dans cet autre sdk streumon du
roman prendre la direction des villages
de ces jeux où nous attend et les nz
nike bonjour hélène ce midi vous nous
parlez d'une innovation technique pour
les cavaliers
bonjour à tous et on va parler
innovation de caméra la plus petite
caméra embarquée pour les cavaliers a
été créée par vous un jean-pierre ouais
vous êtes donc le créateur de cette
petite caméra se place ici sous la
visière du casque effectivement c'est la
première caméra effectivement pour les
spurs et qu'est-ce qui va se fixer comme
ceux ci qui est très très légère 1,3848
durable exactement qui est très très
fine et qui peut se fixer donc très
facilement que l'on nous avait créé
cette caméra pourquoi mais en fait
didier c'était j'en avais marre
d'entendre que l'équitation n'était pas
un sport
donc j'ai cherché un moyen de pouvoir
filmer au plus proche de ce que vaut un
cavalier sur serre cavalier
voilà les téléspectateurs peuvent voir
ce que ça donne on est vraiment la place
du cavalier là on voit des images de
cross exactement c'est à dire qu'il ya
l'image et le son en en temps jusqu'à la
respiration du cavalier et donc on peut
dire que c'est réellement un sport en
voyant ces vidéos qui sont vraiment
ultra réaliste c'est ça pour pour la khl
âge l'équipe de france des gemmes sur
l'endurance la tester mais on ne peut
pas avoir des images et puis vous allez
développer à plein de deux caméras comme
ça pour d'autres sports exactement
aujourd'hui c'est notre première caméra
pour l'esprit de caisse merci beaucoup
je suis obligé un petit peu de vous
couper mais voilà ça donne une idée puis
sinon faut venir ici sur le stand
merci hélène christian choupin bonjour
les jeux équestres continue cet après
midi sur france 3 et oui on fait le
plein d'invités normand cet après midi
puisque on va recevoir l'intégralité de
l'équipe de france de saut d'obstacles
on va revenir sur ce scénario
merveilleux de la médaille d'argent
distribué hier et on aura aussi comme
invités pierre durand qui se présente
donc pour l'élection pour être à la tête
de la fédération internationale équestre
on parlera de tout ça cet après midi dès
15 heures merci à vous on ne manquera
pas de suivre les programmes cet après
midi sur france 3 un grand merci à toute
l'équipe de france télé sport qui nous
accompagne sur ses douces rennes en
direct des jeux équestres mondiaux les
jeux qui reviennent ce soir dans votre
présenté par sylvain rouil pour l'heure
le 12/13 se poursuit avec d'abord la
météo puis votre journal national très
bonne journée à tous et à bientôt